Today starts a two-lecture
sequence on the topic of
hashing, which is a really great
technique that shows up in a lot
of places.
So we're going to introduce it
through a problem that comes up
often in compilers called the
symbol table problem.
And the idea is that we have a
table S holding n records where
each record, just to be a little
more explicit here.
So each record typically has a
bunch of, this is record x.
x is usually a pointer to the
actual data.
So when we talk about the
record x, what it usually means
some pointer to the data.
And in the data,
in the record,
so this is a record,
there is a key called a key of
x.
In some languages it's key,
it's x dot key or x arrow key,
OK, are other ways that that
will be denoted in some
languages.
And there's usually some
additional data called satellite
data, which is carried around
with the key.
This is also true in sorting,
but usually you're sorting
records.
You're not sorting individual
keys.
And so the idea is that we have
a bunch of operations that we
would like to do on this data on
this table.
So we want to be able to insert
an item x into the table,
which just essentially means
that we update the table by
adding the element x.
We want to be able to delete an
item from the table --
-- so removing the item x from
the set and we want to be able
to search for a given key.
So this returns the value x
such that key of x is equal to
k, where it returns nil if
there's no such x.
So be able to insert items in,
delete them and also look to
see if there's an item that has
a particular key.
So notice that delete doesn't
take a key.
Delete takes a record.
OK, so if you want to delete
something of a particular key
and you don't happen to have a
pointer to it,
you have to say let me search
for it and then delete it.
So these, whenever you have a
set operations,
where operations that change
the set like in certain delete,
we call it a dynamic set.
So these two operations make
the set dynamic.
It changes over time.
Sometimes you want to build a
fixed data structure.
It's going to be a static set.
All you're going to do is do
things like look it up and so
forth.
But most often,
it turns out that in
programming and so forth,
we want to have the set be
dynamic.
Want to be able to add elements
to it, delete elements to it and
so forth.
And there may be other
operations that modify the set,
modify membership in the set.
So the simplest implementation
for this is actually often
overlooked.
I'm actually surprised how
often people use more
complicated data structures when
this simple data structure will
work.
It's called a direct access
table.
Doesn't always work.
I'll give the conditions where
it does.
So it works when the keys are
drawn from our small
distribution.
So suppose the keys are drawn
from a set U of m elements.
OK, zero to m minus one.
And we're going to assume the
keys are distinct.
So the way a direct access
table works is that you set up
an array T --
-- from zero to m minus one to
represent the dynamic set S --
-- such that T of k is going to
be equal to x if x is in the set
and its key is k and nil
otherwise.
So you just simply have an
array and if you have a record
whose key is some value k,
the key is 15 say,
then slot 15 if the element is
there has the element.
And if it's not in the set,
it's nil.
Very simple data structure.
OK, insertion.
Just go to that location and
set the value to the inserted
value.
For deletion,
just remove it from there.
And to look it up,
you just index it and see
what's in that slot.
OK, very simple data structure.
All these operations,
therefore, take constant time
in the worst case.
But as a practical matter,
the places you can use this
strategy are pretty limited.
What's the issue of limitation
here?
Yes.
OK, so that's a limitation
surely.
But there's actually a more
severe limitation.
Yeah.
What does that mean,
it's hard to draw?
No.
Yeah.
m minus one could be a huge
number.
Like for example,
suppose that I want to have my
set drawn over 64 bit values.
OK, the things that I'm storing
in my table is a set of 64-bit
numbers.
And so, maybe a small set.
Maybe we only have a few
thousand of these elements.
But they're drawn from a 64-bit
value.
Then this strategy requires me
to have an array that goes from
zero to 2 to the 64th minus one.
How big is 2^64 minus one?
Approximately?
It's like big.
It's like 18 quintillion or
something.
I mean, it's zillions literally
because it's like it's beyond
the illions we normally use.
Not a billion or a trillion.
It's 18 quintillion.
OK, so that's a really big
number.
So, or even worse,
suppose the keys were drawn
from character strings,
so people's names or something.
This would be an awful way to
have to represent it.
Because most of the table would
be empty for any reasonable set
of values you would want to
keep.
So the idea is we want to try
to keep something that's going
to keep the table small,
while still preserving some of
the properties.
And that's where hashing comes
in.
So hashing is we use a hash
function H which maps the keys
randomly.
And I'm putting that in quotes
because it's not quite at
random.
Into slots table T.
So we call each of the array
indexes here a slot.
So you can just sort of think
of it as a big table and you've
got slots in the table where
you're storing your values.
And so, we may have a big
universe of keys.
Let's call that U.
And we have our table over here
that we've set up that has --
-- m slots.
And so we actually have then a
set that we're actually going to
try to represent S,
which is presumably a very
small piece of the universe.
And what we'll do is we'll take
an element from here and map it
to let's say to there and take
another one and we apply the
hash function to the element.
And what the hash function is
going to give us is it's going
to give us a particular slot.
Here's one that might go up
here.
Might have another one over
here that goes down to there.
And so, we get it to distribute
the elements over the table.
So what's the problem that's
going to occur as we do this?
So far, I've been a little bit
lucky.
What's the problem potentially
going to be?
Yeah, when two things are in S,
more specifically,
get assigned to the same value.
So I may have a guy here and he
gets mapped to the same slot
that somebody else has already
been mapped to.
And when this happens,
we call that a collision.
So we're trying to map these
things down into a small set but
we could get unlucky in our
mapping, particularly if we map
enough of these guys.
They're not going to fit.
So when a record --
-- to be inserted maps to an
already occupied slot --
-- a collision occurs.
OK.
So looks like this method's no
good.
But no, there's a pretty simple
thing we can do.
What should we do when two
things map to the same slot?
If we want to represent the
whole set, but you can't lose
any data, can't treat it like a
cache.
In a cache what you do is it
uses a hashing scheme,
but in a cache,
you just kick it out because
you don't care about
representing a set precisely.
But in a hash table you're
programming, you often want to
make sure that the values you
have are exactly the values in
the sets so you can tell whether
something belongs to the set or
not.
So what's a good strategy here?
Yeah.
Create a list for each slot and
just put all the elements that
hash to the same slot into the
list.
And that's called resolving
collisions by chaining.
And the idea is to link records
in the same slot --
-- into a list.
So for example,
imagine this is my hash table
and this for example is slot i.
I may have several things that
are, so I'm going to put the key
value --
-- have several things that may
have been inserted into this
table that are elements of S.
And what I'll do is just link
them together.
OK, so nil pointer here.
And this is the satellite data
and these are the keys.
So if they're all linked
together in slot i,
then the hash function applied
to 49 has got to be equal to the
hash function of 86 is equal to
the hash function of 52,
which equals what?
There's only one thing I
haven't.
i.
Good.
Even if you don't understand
it, your quizmanship should tell
you.
He didn't mention i.
That's equal to i.
So the point is when I hash 49,
the hash of 49 produces me some
index in the table,
say i, and everything that
hashes to that same location is
linked together into a list
OK.
Every record.
Any questions about what the
mechanics of this.
I hope that most of you have
seen this, seen hashing,
basic hashing in 6.001,
right?
They teach it in?
They used to teach it 6.001.
Yeah.
OK.
Some people are saying maybe.
They used to teach it.
Good.
So let's analyze this strategy.
The analysis.
We'll first do worst case.
So what happens in the worst
case?
With hashing?
Yeah, raise your hand so that I
could call on you.
Yeah.
Yeah, all hash keys,
well all, all the keys in S.
I happen to pick a set S where
my hash function happens to map
them all to the same value.
That would be bad.
So every key hashes to the same
slot.
And so, therefore if that
happens, then what I've
essentially built is a fancy
linked list for keeping this
data structure.
All this stuff with the tables,
the hashing,
etc., irrelevant.
All that matters is that I have
a long linked list.
And then how long does an
access take?
How long does it take me to
insert something or well,
more importantly,
to search for something.
Find out whether something's in
there.
In the worst case.
Yeah, it takes order n time.
Because they're all just a
link, we just have a linked
list.
So access takes data n time if
as we assume the size of S is
equal to n.
So from a worst case point of
view, this doesn't look so
attractive.
And we will see data structures
that in worst case do very well
for this problem.
But they don't do as good as
the average case of hashing.
So let's analyze the average
case.
In order to analyze the average
case, I have to,
whenever you have averages,
whenever you have probability,
you have to state your
assumptions.
You have to say what is the
assumption about the behavior of
the system.
And it's very hard to do that
because you don't know
necessarily what the hash
function is.
Well, let's imagine an ideal
hash function.
What should an ideal hash
function do?
Yeah, map the keys essentially
at random to a slot.
Should really distribute them
randomly.
So we call this the assumption
--
-- of simple uniform hashing.
And what it means is that each
key k in S is equally likely --
-- to be hashed to any slot in
T and we're actually have to
make an independence assumption.
Independent of where other
records, other keys are hashed.
So we're going to make this
assumption and includes n an
independence assumption.
That if I have two keys the
odds that they're hashed to the
same place is therefore what?
What are the odds that two keys
under this assumption are hashed
to the same slot,
if I have, say,
m slots?
One over m.
What are the odds that one key
is hashed to slot 15?
One over m.
Because they're being
distributed, but the odds in
particular two keys are hashed
to the same slot,
one over m.
So let's define.
Is there a question?
No.
OK.
The load factor of a hash table
with n keys at m slots to be
alpha which is equal to n over
m, which is also if you think
about it, just the average
number of keys per slot.
So alpha is the average number
of keys per, we call it the load
factor of the table.
OK.
How many on average keys do I
have?
So the expected,
we'll look first at
unsuccessful search time.
So by unsuccessful search,
I mean I'm looking for
something that's actually not in
the table.
It's going to return nil.
I look for a key that's not in
the table.
It's going to be what?
It's going to be order.
Well, I have to do a certain
amount of work just to calculate
the hash function and so forth.
It's going to be order at least
one plus, then I have to search
the list and on average how much
of the list do I have to search?
What's the cost of searching
that list?
On average.
If I'm searching at random.
If I'm searching for a key
that's not in the table.
Whichever one it is,
I got to search to the end of
the list, right?
So what's the average cost over
all the slots in the table?
Alpha.
Right?
That's the average length of a
list.
So this is essentially the cost
of doing the hash and then
accessing the slot and that is
just the cost of searching the
list.
So the expected unsuccessful
search time is proportional
essentially to alpha and if
alpha's bigger than one,
it's order alpha.
If alpha's less than one,
it's constant.
So when is the expected search
time --
-- equal to order one?
So when is this order one?
Simple questions,
by the way.
I only ask simple questions.
Some guys ask hard questions.
Yeah.
Or in terms first we'll get
there in two steps,
OK.
In terms of alpha,
it's when?
When alpha is constant.
If alpha in particular is.
Alpha doesn't have to be
constant.
It could be less than constant.
It's O of one,
right.
OK, or equivalently,
which is what you said,
if n is O of m.
OK, which is to say if the
number of elements in the table
is order, is upper bounded by a
constant times n.
Then the search cost is
constant.
So a lot of people will tell
you oh, a hash table runs in
constant search time.
OK, that's actually wrong.
It depends upon the load factor
of the hash table.
And people have made
programming errors based on that
misunderstanding of hash tables.
Because they have a hash table
that's too small for the number
of elements they're putting in
there.
Doesn't help.
The number may in fact will
grow with the,
since this is one plus n over
m, it actually grows with n.
So unless you make sure that m
keeps up with n,
this doesn't stay constant.
Now it turns out for a
successful search,
it's also one plus alpha.
And for that you need to do a
little bit more mathematics
because you now have to
condition on searching for the
items in the table.
But it turns out it's also one
plus alpha and that you can read
about in the book.
And also, there's a more
rigorous proof of this.
I sort of have glossed over the
expectation stuff here,
doing sort of a more intuitive
proof.
So both of those things you
should look for in the book.
So this is one reason why
hashing is such a popular
method, is it basically lets you
represent a dynamic set with
order one cost per operation,
constant cost per operation,
inserting, deleting and so
forth, as long as the table that
you're keeping is not much
smaller than the number of items
that you're putting in there.
And then all the operations end
up being constant time.
But it depends upon,
strongly upon this assumption
of simple uniform hashing.
And so no matter what hash
function you pick,
I can always find a set of
elements that are going to hash,
that that hash function is
going to hash badly.
I just could generate a whole
bunch of them and look to see
where the hash function takes
them and in the end pick a whole
bunch that hash to the same
place.
We're actually going to see a
way of countering that,
but in practice people
understand that most programs
that need to use things aren't
really reverse engineering the
hash function.
And so, there's some very
simple hash functions that seem
to work fairly well in practice.
So in choosing a hash function
--
-- we would like it to
distribute
-- keys uniformly into slots
and we also would like that
regularity in the key
distributions --
-- should not affect
uniformity.
For example,
a regularity that you often see
is that all the keys that are
being inserted are even numbers.
Somebody happens to have that
property of his data,
that they're only inserting
even numbers.
In fact, on many machines,
since they use byte pointers,
if they're sorting things that
are for example,
indexes to arrays or something
like that, in fact,
they're numbers that are
typically divisible by four.
Or by eight.
So you don't want regularity in
the key distribution to affect
the fact that you're
distributing slots.
So probably the most popular
method that's used just for a
quick hash function is what's
called the division method.
And the idea here is that you
simply let h of k for a key
equal k modulo m,
where m is the number of slots
in your table.
And this works reasonably well
in practice, but you want to be
careful about your choice of
modulus.
In other words,
it turns out it doesn't work
well for every possible size of
table you might want to pick.
Fortunately when you're
building hash tables,
you don't usually care about
the specific size of the table.
If you pick it around some
size, that's probably fine
because it's not going to affect
their performance.
So there's no need to pick a
specific value.
In particular,
you don't want to pick --
-- m with a small divisor --
-- and let me illustrate why
that's a bad idea for this
particular hash function.
I should have said small
divisor d.
So for example --
-- if D is two,
in other words m is an even
number, and it turns out that we
have the situation I just
mentioned, all keys are even,
what happens to my usage of the
hash table?
So I have an even slot,
even number of slots,
and all the keys that the user
of the hash table chooses to
pick happen to be even numbers,
what's going to happen in terms
of my use of the hash table?
Well, in the worst case,
they are always all going to
point in the same slot no matter
what hash function I pick.
But here, let's say that,
in fact, my hash function does
do a pretty good job of
distributing,
but I have this property.
What's a property that's going
to have no matter what set of
keys I pick that satisfies this
property?
What's going to happen to the
hash table?
So, I have even number,
mod an even number.
What does that say about the
hash function?
It's even, right?
I have an even number mod.
It's even.
So, what's going to happen to
my use of the table?
Yeah, you're never going to
hash anything to an odd-numbered
slot.
You wasted half your slots.
It doesn't matter what the key
distribution is.
OK, as long as they're all
even, OK, that means the odds
slots are never used.
OK, an extreme example,
here's another example,
imagine that m is equal to two
to the r.
In other words,
all its factors are small
divisors, OK?
In that case,
if I think about taking k mod
n, OK, the hash doesn't even
depend on all the bits of k,
OK?
So, for example,
suppose I had one...,
and r equals six,
OK, so m is two to the sixth.
So, I take this binary number,
mod two to the sixth,
what's the hash value?
If I take something mod a power
of two, what does it do?
So, I hash this function.
This is k, OK,
in binary.
And I take it mod two to the
sixth.
Well, if I took it mod two,
what's the answer?
What's this number mod two?
Zero, right.
OK, what's this number mod
four?
One zero.
What is it mod two to the
sixth?
Yeah, it's just these last six
bits.
This is H of k.
OK, when you take something mod
a power of two,
all you're doing is taking its
low order bits.
OK, mod two to the r,
you are taking its r low order
bits.
So, the hash function doesn't
even depend on what's up here.
So, that's a pretty bad
situation because generally you
would like a very common
regularity that you'll see in
data is that all the low order
bits are the same,
and all the high order bits
differ, or vice versa.
So, this particular is not a
very good one.
So, good heuristics for this is
to pick m to be a prime,
not too close to a power of two
or ten because those are the two
common bases that you see
regularity in the world.
A prime is sometimes
inconvenient,
however.
But generally,
it's fairly easy to find
primes.
And there's a lot of nice
theorems about primes.
So, generally what you do,
if you're just coding up
something and you know what it
is, you can pick a prime out of
a textbook or look it up on the
web or write a little program,
or whatever,
and pick a prime.
Not too close to a power of two
or ten, and it will probably
work pretty well.
It will probably work pretty
well.
So, this is a very popular
method, the division method.
OK, but the next method we are
going to see is actually usually
superior.
The reason people do this is
because they can write in-line
in their code.
OK, but it's not usually the
best method.
And the reason is because
division, one of the reasons is
division tends to take a lot of
cycles to compute on most
computers compared with
multiplication or addition.
OK, in fact,
it's usually done with taking
several multiplications.
So, the next method is actually
generally better,
but none of the hash function
methods that we are talking
about today are,
in some sense,
provably good hash functions.
OK, so for the multiplication
method, the nice thing about it
is just essentially requires
multiplication to do.
And, for that is,
also, we are going to assume
that the number of slots is a
power of two which is also often
very convenient.
OK, and for this,
we're going to assume that the
computer has w bit words.
So, it would be convenient on a
computer with 32 bits,
or 64 bits, for example.
OK, this would be very
convenient.
So, the hash function is the
following.
h of k is equal to A times k
mod, two to the w,
right shifted by w minus r.
OK, so the key part of this is
A, which has chosen to be an odd
integer in the range between two
to the w minus one and two to
the w.
OK, so it's an odd integer that
the full width of the computer
word.
OK, and what you do is multiply
it by whatever your key is,
by this funny integer.
And, then take it mod two to
the w.
And then, you take the result
and right shift it by this fixed
amount, w minus r.
So, this is a bit wise right
shift.
OK, so let's look at what this
does.
But first, let me just give you
a couple of tips on how you
pick, or what you don't pick for
A.
So, you don't pick A too close
to a power of two.
And, it's generally a pretty
fast method because
multiplication mod two to the w
is faster than division.
And the other thing is that a
right shift is fast,
especially because this is a
known shift.
OK, you know it before you are
computing the hash function.
Both w and r are known in
advance.
So, the compiler can often do
tricks there to make it go even
faster.
So, let's do an example to
understand how this hash
function works.
So, we will have,
in this case,
a number of slots will be
eight, which is two to the
three.
And, we'll have a bizarre word
size of seven bits.
Anybody know any seven bit
computers out there?
OK, well, here's one.
So, A is our fixed value that's
used for hashing all our keys.
And, in this case,
let's say it's 1011001.
So, that's A.
And, I take in some value for k
that I'm going to multiply.
So, k is going to be 1101011.
So, that's my k.
And, I multiply them.
What I multiply two,
each of these is the full word
width.
You can view it as the full
word width of the machine,
in this case,
seven bits.
So, in general,
this would be like a 32 bit
number, and my key,
I'd be multiplying two 32 bit
numbers, for example.
OK, and so, when I multiply
that out, I get a 2w bit answer.
So, when you multiply two w bit
numbers, you get a 2w bit
answer.
In this case,
it happens to be that number,
OK?
So, that's the product part,
And then we take it mod two to
the w.
Well, what mod two to the w
says is that I'm just taking,
ignoring the high order bits of
this product.
So, all of these are ignored,
because, remember that if I
take something,
mod, a power of two,
that's just the low order bits.
So, I just get these low order
bits as being the mod.
And then, the right shift
operation, and that's good also,
by the way, because a lot of
machines, when I multiply two 32
bit numbers, they'll have an
instruction that gives you just
the 32 lower bits.
And, it's usually an
instruction that's faster than
the instruction that gives you
the full 64 bit answer.
OK, so, that's very convenient.
And, the second thing is,
then, that I want just the,
in this case,
three bits that are the high
order bits of this word.
So, this ends up being my H of
k.
And these end up getting
removed by right shifting this
word over.
So, you just right shift that
in, zeros come in,
in a high order bit,
and you end up getting that
value of H of k.
OK, so to understand what's
going on here,
why this is a pretty good
method, or what's happening with
it, you can imagine that one way
to think about it is to think of
A as being a binary fraction.
So, imagine that the decimal
point is here,
sorry, the binary point,
OK, the radix point is here.
Then when I multiply things,
I'm just taking,
the binary point ends up being
there.
OK, so if you just imagine that
conceptually,
we don't have to actually put
this into the hardware because
we just do what the hardware
does.
But, I can imagine that it's
there, and that it's here.
And so, what I'm really taking
is the fractional part of this
product if I treat A as a
fraction of a number.
So, we can certainly look at
that as sort of a modular wheel.
So, here I have a wheel where
this is going to be,
that I'm going to divide into
eight parts, OK,
where this point is zero.
And then, I go around,
and this point is then one.
And, I go around,
and this point is two,
and so forth,
so that all the integers,
if I wrap it around this unit
wheel, all the integers lined up
at the zero point here,
OK?
And then, we can divide this
into the fractional pieces.
So, that's essentially the zero
point.
This is the one eighth,
because we are dividing into
eight, two, three,
four, five, six,
seven.
So, if I have one times A,
in this case,
I'm basically saying,
well, one times A,
if I multiply,
is basically going around to
about there, five and a half I
think, right,
because one times A is about
five and a half,
OK, or five halves of 5.5
eighths, essentially.
So, it takes me about to there.
That's A.
And, if I do 2^A,
that continues around,
and takes me up to about,
where?
About, a little past three,
about to there.
So, that's 2^A.
OK, and 3^A takes me,
then, around to somewhere like
about there.
So, each time I add another A,
it's taking me another A's
distance around.
And, the idea is that if A is,
for example,
odd, and it's not too close to
a power of two,
then what's happening is sort
of throwing it into another slot
on a different thing.
So, if I now go around,
if I have k being very big,
then k times A is going around
k times.
Where does it end up?
It's like spinning a wheel of
fortune or something.
OK, it ends somewhere.
OK, and so that's basically the
notion.
That's basically the notion,
that it's going to end up in
some place.
So, you're basically looking
at, where does ka end up?
Well, it sort of whirls around,
and ends up at some point.
OK, and so that's why that
tends to be a fairly good one.
But, these are only heuristic
methods for hashing,
because for any hash function,
you can always find a set of
keys that's going to make it
operate badly.
So, the question is,
well, what do you use in
practice?
OK, the second topic that I
want to tie it,
so, we talked about resolving
collisions by chaining.
OK, there's another way of
resolving collisions,
which is often useful,
which is resolving collisions
by what's called open
addressing.
OK, and the idea is,
in this method,
is we have no storage for
links.
So, when I result by chaining,
I'd need an extra linked field
in each record in order to be
able to do that.
Now, that's not necessarily a
big overhead,
but for some applications,
I don't want to have to touch
those records at all.
OK, and for those,
open addressing is a useful way
to resolve collisions.
So, the idea is,
with open addressing,
is if I hash to a given slot,
and the slot is full,
OK, what I do is I just hash
again with a different hash
function, with my second hash
function.
I check that slot.
OK, if that slot is full,
OK, then I hash again.
And, I keep this probe
sequence, which hopefully is a
permutation so that I'm not
going back and checking things
that I've already checked until
I find a place to put it.
And, if I got a good probe
sequence that I will hopefully,
then, find a place to put it
fairly quickly.
OK, and then to search,
I just follow the same probe
sequence.
So, the idea,
here, is we probe the table
systematically until an empty
slot is found,
OK?
And so, we can extend that by
looking as if the sequence of
hash functions were,
in fact, a hash function that
took two arguments:
a key and a probe step.
In other words,
is it the zero of one our first
one?
It's the second one,
etc.
So, it takes two arguments.
So, H is then going to map our
universe of keys cross,
our probe number into a slot.
So, this is the universe of
keys.
This is the probe number.
And, this is going to be the
slot.
Now, as I mentioned,
the probe sequence should be
permutation.
In other words,
it should just be the numbers
from zero to n minus one in some
fairly random order.
OK, it should just be
rearranged.
And the other thing about open
addressing is that you don't
have to worry about n chaining
is that the table may actually
fill up.
So, you have to have that the
number of elements in the table
is less than or equal to the
table size, the number of slots
because the table may fill up.
And, if it's full,
you're going to probe
everywhere.
You are never going to get a
place to put it.
And, the final thing is that in
this type of scheme,
deletion is difficult.
It's not impossible.
There are schemes for doing
deletion.
But, it's basically hard
because the danger is that you
remove a key out of the table,
and now, somebody who's doing a
probe sequence who would have
hit that key and gone to find
his element now finds that it's
an empty slot.
And he says,
oh, the key I am looking for
probably isn't there.
OK, so you have that issue to
deal with.
So, you can delete things but
keep them marked,
and there's all kinds of
schemes that people have for
doing deletion.
But it's difficult.
It's messy compared to
chaining, where you can just
remove the element out of the
chain.
So, let's do an example --
-- just so that we make sure
we're on the same page.
So, we'll insert a key.
k is 496.
OK, so here's my table.
And, I've got some values in
it, 586, 133,
204, 481, etc.
So, the table looks like that;
the other places are empty.
So, on my zero step,
I probe H of 496,
zero.
OK, and let's say that takes me
to the slot where there's 204.
And so, I say,
oh, there's something there.
I have to probe again.
So then, I probe H of 496,
one.
Maybe that maps me there,
and I discover,
oh, there's something there.
So, now, I probe H of 496,
two.
Maybe that takes me to there.
It's empty.
So, if I'm doing a search,
I report nil.
If I'm doing in the insert,
I put it there.
And then, if I'm looking for
that value, if I put it there,
then when I'm looking,
I go through exactly the same
sequence.
I'll find these things are
busy, and then,
eventually, I'll come up and
discover the value.
OK, and there are various
heuristics that people use,
as well, like keeping track of
the longest probe sequence
because there's no point in
probing beyond the largest
number of probes that need to be
done globally to do an
insertion.
OK, so if it took me 5,
5 is the maximum number of
probes I ever did for an
insertion.
A search never has to look more
than five, OK,
and so sometimes hash tables
will keep that auxiliary value
so that it can quit rather than
continuing to probe until it
doesn't find something.
OK, so, search is the same
probe sequence.
And, if it's successful,
it finds the record.
And, if it's unsuccessful,
you find a nil.
OK, so it's pretty
straightforward.
So, once again,
as with just hash functions to
begin with, there are a lot of
ideas about how you should form
a probe sequence,
ways of doing this effectively.
OK, so the simplest one is
called linear probing,
and what you do there is you
have H of k comma i.
You just make that be some H
prime of k, zero plus i mod m.
Sorry, no prime there.
OK, so what happens is,
so, the idea here is that all
you are doing on the I'th probe
is, on the zero'th probe,
you look at H of k zero.
On probe one,
you just look at the slot after
that.
Probe two, you look at the slot
after that.
So, you're just simply,
rather than sort of jumping
around like this,
you probe there and then just
find the next one that will fit
in.
OK, so you just scan down mod
m.
So, if you hit the bottom,
you go to the top.
OK, so the I'th one,
so that's fairly easy to do
because you don't have to
recomputed a full hash function
each time.
All you have to do is add one
each time you go because the
difference between this and the
previous one is just one.
OK, so you just go down.
Now, the problem with that is
that you get a phenomenon of
clustering.
If you get a few things in a
given area, then suddenly
everything, everybody has to
keep searching to the end of
those things.
OK, so that turns out not to be
one of the better schemes,
although it's not bad if you
just need to do something quick
and dirty.
So, it suffers from primary
clustering, where regions of the
hash table get very full.
And then, anything that hashes
into that region has to look
through all the stuff that's
there.
OK, so: long runs of filled
slots.
OK, there's also things like
quadratic clustering,
where you basically make this
be, instead of adding one each
time, you add i each time.
OK, but probably the most
effective popular scheme is
what's called double hashing.
And, you can do statistical
studies.
People have done statistical
studies to show that this is a
good scheme, OK,
where you let H of k,
i, let me do it below here
because I have for them.
So, H of k, i is equal to an
H_1 of k plus i times H_2 of k.
So, you have two hash functions
on m.
You have two hash functions,
H_1 of k and H_2 of k.
OK, so you compute the two hash
functions, and what you do is
you start by just using H_1 of k
for the zero probe,
because here,
i, then, will be zero.
OK.
Then, for the probe number one,
OK, you just add H_2 of k.
For probe number two,
you just add that hash function
amount again.
You just keep adding H_2 of k
for each successive probe you
make.
So, it's fairly easy;
you compute two hash functions
up front, OK,
or you can delay the second
one, in case.
But basically,
you compute two up front,
and then you just keep adding
the second one in.
You start at the location of
the first one,
and keep adding the second one,
mod m, to determine your probe
sequences.
So, this is an excellent
method.
OK, it does a fine job,
and you usually pick m to be a
power of two here,
OK, so that you're using,
usually people use this with
the multiplication method,
for example,
so that m is a power of two,
and H_2 of k you force to be
odd.
OK, so we don't use and even
value there, because otherwise
for any particular key,
you'd be skipping over.
Once again, you would have the
problem that everything could be
even, or everything could be odd
as you're going through.
But, if you make H_2 of k odd,
and m is a power of two,
you are guaranteed to hit every
slot.
OK, so let's analyze this
scheme.
This turns out to be a pretty
interesting scheme to analyze.
It's got some nice math in it.
So, once again,
in the worst case,
hashing is lousy.
So, we're going to analyze
average case.
OK, and for this,
we need a little bit stronger
assumption than for chaining.
And, we call it the assumption
of uniform hashing,
which says that each key is
equally likely,
OK, to have any one of the m
factorial permutations as its
probe sequence,
independent of other keys.
And, the theorem we're going to
prove is that the expected
number of probes is,
at most, one over one minus
alpha if alpha is less than one,
OK,
that is, if the number of keys
in the table is less than number
of slots.
OK, so we're going to show that
the number of probes is one over
one minus alpha.
So, alpha is the load factor,
and of course,
for open addressing,
we want the load factor to be
less than one because if we have
more keys than slots,
open addressing simply doesn't
work, OK, because you've got to
find a place for every key in
the table.
So, the proof,
we'll look at an unsuccessful
search, OK?
So, the first thing is that one
probe is always necessary.
OK, so if I have n over m,
sorry, if I have n items stored
in m slots, what's the
probability that when I do that
probe I get a collision with
something that's already in the
table?
What's the probability that I
get a collision?
Yeah?
Yeah, n over m,
right?
So, with probability,
n over m, we have a collision
because my table has got n
things in there.
I'm hashing,
at random, to one of them.
OK, so, what are the odds I hit
something, n over m?
And then, a second probe is
necessary.
OK, so then,
I do a second probe.
And, with what probability on
the second probe do I get a
collision?
So, we're going to make the
assumption of uniform hashing.
Each key is equally likely to
have any one of the m factorial
permutations as its probe
sequence.
So, what is the probability
that on the second probe,
OK, I get a collision?
Yeah?
If it's a permutation,
you're not, right?
Something like that.
What is it exactly?
So, that's the question.
OK, so you are not going to hit
the same slot because it's going
to be a permutation.
Yeah?
That's exactly right.
n minus one over m minus one
because I'm now,
I've essentially eliminated
that slot that I hit the first
time.
And so, I have,
now, and there was a key there.
So, now I'm essentially
looking, at random,
into the remaining n minus one
slots where there are
aggregately n minus one keys in
those slots.
OK, everybody got that?
OK, so with that probability,
I get a collision.
That means that I need a third
probe necessary,
OK?
And, we keep going on.
OK, so what is it going to be
the next time?
Yeah, it's going to be n minus
two over m minus two.
So, let's note,
OK, that n minus i over m minus
i is less than n over m,
which equals alpha,
OK?
So, n minus i over m minus i is
less than n over m.
And, the way you can sort of
reason that is that if n is less
than m, I'm subtracting a larger
fraction of n when I subtract i
than I am subtracting a fraction
of m.
OK, so therefore,
n minus i over m minus i is
going to be less than n over m.
OK, so, or you can do the
algebra.
I think it's always helpful
when you do algebra to sort of
think about it sort of
quantitatively as well,
you know, qualitatively what's
going on.
So, the expected number of
probes is, then,
going to be equal to,
it's going to be equal to
because we're going to need some
space, well, we have one which
is forced because we've got to
do one probe,
plus with probability n over m,
I have to do another probe plus
with probability of n over m
minus one I have to do another
probe up until I do one plus one
over m minus n.
OK, so each one is cascading
what's happened.
In the book,
there is a more rigorous proof
of this using indicator random
variables.
I'm going to give you the short
version.
OK, so basically,
this is my first probe.
With probability n over m,
I had to do a second one.
And, the result of that is that
with probability n minus one
over m minus one,
I have to do another.
And, with probability n over
two minus m over two,
I have to do another,
and so forth.
So, that's how many probes I'm
going to end up doing.
So, this is less than or equal
to one plus alpha.
There's one plus alpha times
one plus alpha times one plus
alpha, OK, just using the fact
that I had here.
OK, and that is less than or
equal to one plus I just
multiply through here.
Alpha plus alpha squared plus
alpha cubed plus k.
I can just take that out to
infinity.
It's going to bound this.
OK, does everybody see the math
there?
OK, and that is just the sum,
I, equals zero to infinity,
alpha to the I,
which is equal to one over one
minus alpha using your familiar
geometric series bound.
OK, and there's also,
in the textbook,
an analysis of the successful
search, which,
once again, is a little bit
more technical because you have
to worry about what the
distribution is that you happen
to have in the table when you
are searching for something
that's already in the table.
But, it turns out it's also
bounded by one over one minus
alpha.
So, let's just look to see what
that means.
So, if alpha is less than one
is a constant,
it implies that it takes order
one probes.
OK, so if alpha is a constant,
it takes order one probes.
OK, but it's helpful to
understand what's happening with
the constant.
So, for example,
if the table is 50% full,
so alpha is a half,
what's the expected number of
probes by this analysis?
Two, because one over one minus
a half is two.
If I let the table fill up to
90%, how many probes do I need
on average?
Ten.
So, you can see that as you
fill up the table,
the cost is going dramatically,
OK?
And so, typically,
you don't let the table get too
full.
OK, you don't want to be
pushing 99.9% utilization.
Oh, I got this great hash table
that's got full utilization.
It's like, yeah,
and it's slow.
It's really,
really slow,
OK, because as alpha approaches
one, the time is approaching and
essentially m,
or n.
Good.
So, next time,
we are going to address head-on
in what was one of the most,
I think, interesting ideas in
algorithms.
We are going to talk about how
you solve this problem that no
matter what hash function you
pick, there's a bad set of keys.
OK, so next time we're going to
show that there are ways of
confronting that problem,
very clever ways.
And we use a lot of math for it
so will be a really fun lecture.